when gary johnson ten days ago tabbed as
his potential running mate former
massachusetts governor william weld it
led to one of the largest bursts of
attention in the history of the modern
libertarian party people all throughout
the media were writing there's some
strange new possibilities of foot for
the third party what they probably
didn't count on was that at the
libertarian party convention itself
which is ongoing in orlando florida that
pick would be met with a lot more
skepticism so we're here today with
former governor william weld to talk
about it thank you for joining us a
pleasure thank you so to what do you
attribute this skepticism with which you
have been greeted by some people here
well the members of the party don't know
me i mean they haven't seen me i've been
out of politics ten years they don't
know that on my first day in office in
massachusetts I started my first press
conference by saying fellow libertarians
they don't know that in law school my
favorite author was Friedrich Hayek the
author of the constitution of Liberty
and the road to serfdom they don't know
that when I was governor I went to ed
cranes Cato Institute parties the annual
one in Arizona
virtually every year and I've been a
from time to time financial supporter of
Cato
they're my kind of people I when I went
as a fairly new governor and gave a
speech at the convention in Houston that
nominated George W against Pat Buchanan
all the new governors got to make a
short speech and my began I want the
government out of your pocketbook and
out of your bedroom I'm an economic
conservative and I'm socially tolerant
and inclusive that's some of my
political positions let's talk about
that aspect all right you've been in
politics or around politics for quite a
long time describe kind of the both the
ideological opportunity and then the
pragmatic opportunity when faced with
two candidates like this and two
unfavorability kind of ratings like this
well I think and again nothing's nothing
certain and
not assuming dairy and I'll be the
nominees but just for the sake of
argument if we were I think we have an
opportunity to run right up the middle
because forty to fifty five percent of
the electorate thinks of themselves as
economically conservative and socially
tolerant and that's neither party the
Republicans are not socially tolerant
they want to tell people whether or not
they can have an abortion and tell gays
and lesbians whether they can get
married and live happily ever after and
and so on they want to round up the
immigrants this is a nation of
immigrants I'm sorry you know anyone who
wants to round up the immigrants and
build a huge wall has not read a history
book in a long time the most famous wall
in the 20th century was the Berlin wall
which was completely infamous but we're
gonna have to have the rent of Ronald
Reagan of Mexico shaking his fist on the
other side of the wall saying mr. Trump
you know tear down this wall and he's
gonna have to tear it down cuz we will
be on the wrong side of history in 2006
you almost ran for governor of New York
as a libertarian you eventually withdrew
nomination that some people are upset
about that what has been your
relationship with the Libertarian Party
if at all in the ensuing 10 years I've
admired Gary's embrace of the party in
his run in 2012 I mean I was a finance
co-chair for Mitt Romney in New York in
that race and in 2008 so I couldn't
really cross party lines so speak and
endorse Gary but I told my friends
that's that's a guy you can go vote for
and feel proud about Gary and I were
governors together and late 90s his
first term was my second term so we had
overlap there no I guess since I've had
a crush on the libertarian party from
afar I did have the designation in New
York and I went to them and said please
please please I saw Audrey this
afternoon who actually nominated me from
the floor for the
Libertarian Party in 2006 well that was
a semi disastrous race I mean I crashed
and burned as being a carpetbagger even
though I'm actually a native of New York
State but nobody would believe that
because I've been governor of
Massachusetts last night they had the
vice presidential debate I've heard a
lot from a lot of people on the floor
who were very upset that you said that
the United Nations the United States
should belong to the United Nations what
does it make you feel like when the
party that you want to represent
includes a lot of people who think
that's crazy
well I didn't see that in the platform
which I read in its entirety this
afternoon and I was glad I didn't see it
because I found the world a lot for
client business and I see a lot of
suffering in Africa and Asia and I do
think there are things that the United
Nations can be useful for you know I'm
on board with those who think that NATO
is suffering from a case of mission
creep and that's particularly bad for a
country like ours that has intervention
creep in its recent past and I agree
with Gary and that libertarian party we
got to get away from that no more boots
on the ground no more blood and yet you
endorsed John Kasich he's a huge
intervention you hear him talking about
foreign policy he wants to you know
topple the dictatorship in North Korea
and Syria and redline here and punch
Russia in the nose there what were you
thinking about endorsing John Kasich my
relationship with Kasich is on budgetary
issues Newt Gingrich asked me to come to
Congress in 1995 right after Newt and
those folks had gotten in to to persuade
his members they could take tough votes
on economic issues and budget issues and
still get reelected and I went down
there with John Engler from Michigan
tommy Thompson from Wisconsin we did
that successfully and and Kasich was the
Boy Wonder chair of the House Budget
Committee that Newt had leapfrogged over
12 other people that become chairman
because he did his own budget every year
and he was the acknowledged master of
the budget in the house and he was a
long cool drink of water because he knew
exactly what had to be done in terms of
balancing the budget as we have done in
a state level Senate was a much longer
longer row 200 chairman said do we
really have to balance the budget in
seven years couldn't it be nine years
well that's that's not with the program
as they say so I got to know Kasich very
well there in an area where he's an
authentic American Hero namely the
federal budget you started in politics
your governorship is sort of associated
with the 1990s there was such a thing as
the kind of socially liberal Republican
governor or politician that wasn't that
was a category that existed doesn't seem
to exist I associate it was sort of a
good government mitch Daniels type of
thing people who are interested in in
issues like privatization and other
things where did that go began to go in
1994 when things became much more
partisan when I used to see Newt when he
was Minority Leader before he was
speaker he had a saloon door on his
office because the Dems didn't want him
to be able to have a private meeting
when Newt became Speaker he didn't
forget that so you know the atmosphere
became a little bit more pained in both
directions and then you had
redistricting in 2000 1992 and 2002 and
2012 that just drove both parties to the
extreme because they want to protect
their own members so they gerrymander
the congressional seats so that no
incumbent is going to be defeated and
that means that the only thing an
incumbent is scared of is a challenge
from the right in the Republican Party
or from the left in the Democratic Party
so you get much more extreme members
many fewer who are interested in
compromising in the middle the effect
has not been good for the United States
what has to happen in order for the
Libertarian Party ticket to achieve what
you imagined to be its highest possible
well I don't think we're that far away
in this of all years McGarry is polling
Gary Johnson at 10 percent all by
himself without any bursts of recent
publicity if he and I got a got
to be nominees and got a burst of
publicity that would be a 15% maybe and
that's the level where you get into
presidential debates and you know I
could go around to my fundraising pals
from when I was Pete Wilson's national
finance chair when I was Mitt Romney's
finance co-chair in New York and see if
we could attract many angels of
libertarian leanings and some of these
guys you wouldn't have to persuade about
the Libertarian Party they lean that way
and they could potentially help to fund
either a super PAC or a 501 C 4 which is
another type of account where people can
make large contributions at the same
time I think we should have a Bernie
Sanders web based fundraising operation
because we have an appeal to Millennials
so you need a combination of media
attention and and money in the kitty and
then I think people really have to take
us seriously and we both know what we
think and we can string two or three
sentences together so then we get into
the national dialogue and I think that
20% goes to 25% and from that point it's
Katie bar the door because if there are
three parties there with two months ago
or a month and a half ago or even even a
month to go and it's 45 35 25 that's too
close for the pundits to write anybody
off in a crazy year like this thank you
very much is for reason TV I am Matt
Welch